because at a young age of 18 you said
there's three things that i want to
accomplish it's almost like you were
like manifesting what you wanted to
accomplish like i'm a big believer in um
affirmations like i say an affirmation
every single day or you know when i'm
not maybe hungover or something like
that but still even then in the
afternoon but i say an affirmation every
day but you said there's three things
you wanted to accomplish what were those
three things again uh to be financially
independent to travel and see the world
and make my own schedule and you've been
able to do that yeah my whole life so
break that down how each of those
strings have basically manifested in
your life
so you know financial independence came
early from dancing and then
understanding money you know that's the
next thing making money is one thing but
understanding money al was a big help
for that al's diamond cabaret another
shout out he gets
um traveling and seeing the world you
know when i would interview these women
they would be telling me they were going
to trade shows in australia and germany
and italy and going all over and
everything's paid for by other people
and i'm like this is just unbelievable
and your schedule is
you tell everybody when you want to work
so in this business you reach out and
you're like these are when i want to do
my shoots i don't like to shoot in the
valley in august it's too hot like i've
always claimed my control of my schedule
so those three things were really simple
but i couldn't get them anywhere else
unless i went the adult industry i just
don't think any other career could have
put me on that path so young well would
you consider yourself an entrepreneur
yes a femme
i'm an entrepreneur i've owned multiple
businesses i bought a day spa right
after 9 11 and ran and owned it for four
years and then sold it to a medi-spa so
i've done a lot of different businesses
at a talent agency i i like to build
things and then
turn them and i love to sell you know
selling a business without anybody
knowing it's for sale is like it's a
great it's a beautiful thing well the
reason i ask is because we are the
number one channel for entrepreneurs if
you put entrepreneur into youtube boom
valuetainment pops up yeah we're known
for business and business planning and
entrepreneurship and even some political
stuff and even some money stuff but at
the end of the day we talk about
entrepreneurship so i know a lot of
people out there maybe there's a lot of
fans of lisa and maybe there might be
some
haters everyone's got some haters out
there but i know for a hundred percent
everyone who watches valuetainment will
respect the fact that you are an
entrepreneur how does it make you feel
that you are an entrepreneur in the porn
industry and what should other ladies in
the porn industry understand about
entrepreneurship and making money i
think now that there's so many
applications like only fans and clips
for sale and all the different mediums
that talent is using on their own they
realize now they're entrepreneurs they
know their bosses you know what i mean
they get it by 23 they have 10 people
working for them they have three
assistants they have somebody doing
their social media and they know that
everyone's check relies on them so there
is a greater feel
of the women and men in the industry
being entrepreneurs it's just not talked
about on the outside world because we
don't want to look at this business as
this is where success could come from we
haven't gotten there yet
um to prop up people in the industry is
something people have a very hard time
doing and to look at us as successful
it's even when it comes to a little bit
of dating to throw that in there like i
find that i meet men all the time that
just don't get that i'm successful
they don't get it they think either a
guy gives me money or something it's
like oh my god i don't get that you make
your own money right and that i did the
right things with it and that i live you
know they don't get it and i think
people don't realize how much money is
being made in the industry and how easy
it is to make it